in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 17th, on which we commemorate St. Batoff, Abbot
of Iconho and Adolf, Bishop of Maastricht.
Our Holy Father's Batoff and Adolf were born of noble parents early in the 7th century.
They were taught the Christian faith in England, but went across the channel to France to learn
more.
In France, they received the monastic tonsure and a thorough education in the monastic
life.
According to John of Tynemyth, Adolf was raised to the Episcopate in Maastricht, Holland,
where he led a holy life in all respects.
And in about 654, Batoff returned to England through the intercession of two sisters of King
Ethelman, of East Anglia, who were living in the same French monastery.
He was granted a certain uncultivated place called Iconho, on which to build a monastery.
Now that region, writes John of Tynemyth, was as much forsaken by man as it was possessed
by demons, whose fantastic illusion by the coming of the holy man was to be immediately
put to flight, and the pious conversation of the faithful substituted in its place.
So that whereup to that time the deceit of the devil had abandoned the grace of our beneficent
founder should more abound.
Upon the entry therefore of the blessed Batoff, the blackest smoke arises, and the
enemy, knowing that his own flight was at hand, cries out with horrid clamor, saying,
this place which we have inhabited for a long time, we thought to inhabit forever.
Why, O Batoff, most cruel stranger, does thou violently drive us from these seats?
In nothing have we offended thee, in nothing have we disturbed your right.
What do you seek in our expulsion?
What do you wish to establish in this region of ours?
And after being driven out of every corner of the world, do you expel us wretched, even
out of this solitude?
But the blessed Batoff, having made the sign of the cross, put all his enemies to flight.
Saint Batoff proceeded to build a model community of monks at Iconho, being himself distinguished
by many spiritual gifts, including prophecy.
He instructed St. Chalfred, among many others, and was also invited to take charge of the
new monastery at Muck-Wenluck, at length, he died after a long illness in June of 680, and
many miracles were wrought at his tomb.
In 869, Saint Batoff's monastery was destroyed by the Danes, but in about 972, a
bit at the command of St. Ethelwold, Bishop of Winchester, a band of monks, led by a certain
Ulfkital, came to the Saint's tomb, collected the precious relics, wrapped them in fine linen,
and tried to carry them away on their shoulders.
However, writes John of Tynemyth, they were fixed with so great a weight that by no effort
can they move a step.
Despite the cloister of the altar, resound with a loud noise, as if to intimate that their
work was unfinished.
They are stupified with amazement, but at last by the teachings of God's grace.
The monk of Forced recollects the things he has heard, that the blessed Adolf, the Bishop
was buried with his brother, and having raised the body out of the earth, they carried it with
them to St. Ethelwold, rejoicing.
According to Falkard, the re-open tomb gave forth a miraculous aroma for fifteen days,
and the remains of Batoff could not be removed without those of his brother, Adolf.
St. Ethelwold then placed the head of St. Batoff in the monastery of Ili, part of the rest
of the body together with the body of St. Adolf in the monastery of Thornie, and the
rest in his own monastery at Winchester.
Later, St. Edward the Confessor translated part of the body of St. Batoff to St. Peter's
West Minster.
Sixty-four ancient churches were dedicated to Batoff, sixteen of them in Norfolk, and three
in the city of London.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.